[Music]
it is the rest day and the players are
playing a probe is event top players
playing against amateurs in friendly
competition where the winds don't matter
but yeah they do I'm very pleased
delighted to play with Fabiano is very
gentle he's a very good teacher so we
prepare very strong strategy I think
these guys have no chance he'll actually
seize a lot and like in the first game
he didn't really make any serious
mistakes at all like some minor
inaccuracies but nothing serious I mean
it was an excellent game so it's I don't
feel like we're speaking a different
language so first of all okay I can
teach something it's always good but I
just want to have fun to have fun games
and I hope that you know my partner
without fun with me well we get two
chances to explain something and the
rest is all crosswires in this
communication so it's a lot of fun well
it was a fun and festive day the players
had a good time the amateurs were happy
a wonderful rest day here in Paris